welcome to the Dean show my next guests
coming up from atheism to agnosticism to
beauty pageants and party and play and
fun to having a void that many people
have filling it with all these things a
thousand and one things but none of
these things make that pain inside that
void inside the hurt inside the yearning
to want to know inside why I've been
created why am I here the person
my next guest found out why and she's
here to share her story and how she
wouldn't trade it for the world you can
have it too we'll be right back on a
Deen show with his wonderful story don't
go anywhere be right back this is the
Salam alaikum peace be with you welcome
to the show sister Chelsea how are you
now we hear you can't you come from a
kind of an agnostic atheist background
you went through the whole you know and
I always wonder I I get really in awe
thinking like why is it that many young
women they inspire to be like a star
meaning like you know they want to win
the beauty pageants and this is kind of
what you went through right yes my life
you know I tried that I'm like the
Christian youth groups as a teenager but
I think it was probably more so for the
wrong reasons and socializing and
meeting boys and stuff like that um but
when I got into high school you know of
course I think just like a lot of
Western girls we kind of get into our
looks and being social with other girls
and I started doing USA beauty pageants
pretty much throughout my entire high
school years so for about three or four
years now why the whole eight why'd you
go towards the whole atheism thing I
think for me I always just relied on
faith and a lot of my family is
Christian and the majority of my family
is Christian and I remember just kind of
talking to them briefly and talking to
other Christians that I was socialized
with and everything was based around fee
and for me I just never felt like I had
it when I was in high school I attended
like this hip hop church and the pastor
he like wrapped and he was this white
guy with like cornrows and it was really
fun people would come in breakdance and
it was a place where like teenagers
could feel like they could practice
their religion without being judged for
being teenagers and so it's really great
atmosphere and I remember even going to
the Bible studies and me and a
girlfriend of mine we decided that we
would start reading kind of this urban
trans
relation of the Bible and even then I
would read it and just I was never
connecting I remember you know being in
church and singing the songs and having
a really good time but I remember like
vaguely just being there one time and
being like what am I doing here like I
don't have faith like I don't even like
I don't even know if I believe in this
and I think from that point on I was
just kind of like well if there is a God
you know he'll guiding me somewhere but
right now I just I don't believe in
anything so it really did kind of lead
me to just not believing in anything not
believing that there was a God we see a
little guy back there who's that your
bodyguard what's his name so Chelsea so
many people they kind of go to church
slighted on Sundays you know it's kind
of a traditional thing family friends
but then when you get to the concepts
you know God being a man Jesus dying for
your sins you know the fifth row what we
call the natural inclination inside this
thing that God Almighty put in all of us
it rejects this and then people start to
question it many don't they just again
slide in on Sundays were you one of
those that were going to church's slide
in and not question it and then you came
to a point where you started the
question and then you were really at a
dilemma here you know church was really
just for Christmas Eve and maybe Easter
is for us um you know like I said I kind
of attended your typical like teenage
youth groups and stuff like that in
middle school but for my knowledge I
mean I only understood Christianity to
be as Jesus was the son of God you know
it wasn't until later on in my teenage
years that I started hearing other sects
of Christianity kind of talking about
how Jesus was God and that he was a man
and I think for me I did question a lot
of that I don't think that there was
ever a time in my life that I fully
accepted it because I never
I considered myself a Christian even now
when people are like oh we kind of grew
up in a Christian household or your
family of this Christian but I never
really felt Christian because I never
really felt that way I never felt that
Jesus was the son of God or I questioned
it enough anyways to not really feel
that way how did you get to
investigating about Islam you know in
high school anyways I had a Muslim girl
friend who was important she was
Palestinian born Muslim and when she was
18 years old I ended up getting married
my son wants to be in the show I'm
selling it fell on it when he gets older
we'll get him on we would talk briefly
about it you know but it wasn't anything
big it wasn't really until I was about
25 years older so um that I figured you
know what I kind of checked out all the
other religions that I was even
interested in even going into Buddhism
and things like that and you know
nothing really stuck so I kind of felt
well I don't really have anything to
lose me and her we would kind of have
like small discussions here in thin air
and I was always kind of like well if
there's a god and I think this is kind
of where my agnosticism started to come
in Iraq my 2425 because I was always
that if I was searching for something I
did I wanted something you know I just
never had faith in anything so when she
kept telling me she'll see some of the
things that you kind of talk about if
there was a God and how life should be
and how we should be as people it really
kind of sounds Islamic you know and I
think right then in there I was kind of
like hey well what do I have to lose you
know let me just go ahead and watch some
lectures on YouTube and that's actually
what brought me to your show and Allah I
mean I remember just watching my video
after invidious on your video log on
your website and I would spend hours
like every day for weeks doing that
Raja we're gonna take a break and we
want to talk about this void you had
kind of went through many of the
pursuing many of the pursuits that
people young people they pursue but
there was a
void we're gonna get to that void when
we come back here in a Dean show don't
go anywhere we'll be right back please
subscribe to the video follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
subscribe right now
back here on the Dean show before we
will have to break I talked about a void
many people have it they fill it with
alcohol with drugs they fall into peer
pressure pursuing to be a star beauty
pageants you name it they do it a
thousand and one purposes except the
true purpose talk about this void that
you had a girl who like I had tons of
friends but I always felt lonely you
know it's like I was always trying to
find confidence but I was that person
that was always you know telling people
to have self-love you know I always felt
like something was missing and I never
really knew what it was and so for me
you know naturally just as like a young
western girl you know I lived kind of
the party lifestyle and I worked as a
cocktail waitress at a bar and you know
so of course that had me out a lot I
would go to the clubs I mean at one
point right before I converted actually
I mean I was going out anywhere from
three to four nights a week you know and
I was I was drinking a lot and you know
but it was never anything I felt like I
had an issue with I just felt like I
know it was just being a young girl
having fun um you know and I
unfortunately ended up kind of trying to
fill that void with other things that I
won't really you know go into detail
about but you know it really just left
me more empty and I remember when I
started looking into Islam um you know I
almost kind of started to like feel like
this genuine happiness kind of start to
come into play like things are going to
be okay
and I didn't feel that in you know that
emptiness as much anyway
and now come the law you know four and a
half years later after converting I can
honestly say that I am the most
genuinely happy I have ever been in my
entire life Abdullah would you trade it
for the world what is happiness that you
have now oh no way
no way my goal is beautiful tell us also
how do you feel especially right now
when you see this beautiful way of life
that was lived by Jesus Moses Abraham
you know that simple call to have a
loving relationship to connect your
heart with the Creator who created the
heart this way of life of Islam being
defamed by many of these politicians now
how do you how do you feel how does that
make you feel
disheartening um you know I've always
been a very optimistic person I have
always been somebody who really looks
and the good in people a good in society
and I truly believe that God made us
inherently good I mean you know we're
made of light you know so he knew that
there was some good in us and you know
for me it's like I'm you know it's kind
of one of those ignorance can create
hate and you know ignorance is bliss in
a way you know but it's really just kind
of disheartening I think you know
especially for me as a woman who I wear
my religion on my head you know and so
for me with a young child going out in
public especially now it's like there's
almost kind of this level of fear that I
feel is very unnecessary and I really
think that it has to do with people just
being uneducated and them educating
themselves in the wrong way from the
wrong sources and I think that it's
really important for us as a Muslim
Ummah to kind of come together and
create these educational resources for
these people so that we don't have you
know these misconceptions these
misunderstandings from people have you
ever had a real situation where
must come up to you at random and asked
you about Islam or was inquisitive to
know or give you a hard time and you and
you had a chance to communicate with
such a person and communicate what Islam
was really about other than I've
actually had a lot of occasions and I
think that one is because I am a woman
in the West wearing hijab and I think
that too you know
Oh unfortunately a lot of people in the
West do stereotype of Muslims as being
you know a darker color and Arab and
Indian things like this so when they see
somebody like me who you know is blue
eyes light skin you know they're a
little bit more intrigued and maybe even
unfortunately at times a little bit more
at ease to talk to me um you know I work
a job publicly while I was working
before I was pregnant and a bit during
while I was pregnant
yes so uh and you know so for me I
encountered a lot of people asking
questions about my religion why I work a
job or sure your comments of oh did your
husband make you wear that and you think
like that I did unfortunately encounter
one negative
you know conversation with a young
gentleman and I think you know of course
as a new Muslim you know even at times
we kind of have to learn to control
ourselves a bit and I think it kind of
became a little bit more of a
back-and-forth and if maybe I had
restrained myself a bit maybe it
wouldn't have caught it as bad as it did
but I got to the point where you know it
was kind of cussing at me and telling me
to go back to my country and laugh
because I was like well I'm here hello
you know because I'm white Asian
American born you know and it's really
sad that most people have these horrible
stereotypes in their head you know that
it's managed somehow is in relation to
an ethnicity or a nationality which of
course we know is
crow but thankfully I have had a lot of
opportunities to speak to people about
my religion and kind of clear up some
misconceptions which has been really
nice I think beneficial to me have you
had family members or some of these
people asked you like so what now you've
become you know terror radical and how
do you respond to that has anybody has
associated with you now as a suspect now
because you're Muslim automatically you
think okay you've become some radical
extremists oh yeah oh yeah you know I
was still kind of going through an old
marriage of mine where my ex-husband was
actually a United States Marine and you
know so my family of course was very
used to me being kind of in this
military go America lifestyle and so
when I had told my family that I had
decided to convert to Islam I remember
one family member in particular kind of
came at me and was like so then what are
you like against America now and like I
just it's like I almost didn't even know
what to say to that like my religion
doesn't make me against Sri you know
maybe some of its actions at times but I
mean we could say that in our countries
all over the world you know so for me
it's like me wearing my congestion make
me radical just because I'm choosing to
you know follow my faith I mean I am
probably one of the nicest people ever
you know it's like when you actually sit
down and talk to me and this is what
happened with a lot of the women who
have confronted me in my pastor or a
non-muslim ask me any question kind of
like you're just like a normal girl and
I'm wonderful thank you for seeing that
I wish more people understood that
Muslims are just regular people and that
this is just their religion you know and
again it just it comes down to ignorance
we're gonna take a break and we'll be
right back with more here on the Deen
show don't go anywhere please subscribe
to the DCO follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
subscribe right now
back to the D show tell us Chelsea did
you have once you we know that any
sincere individual human being that
really looks into Islam seeking to know
the truth they will find what they're
looking for in it but many people
sometimes they have these reservations
because what's my family going to say
society it's not the cool thing as you
can see did you have some of these
apprehensions and reservations when you
start to recognize that this was indeed
the true from the Creator very outgoing
a confident person and I'm somebody
who's always stood by my beliefs and
never really cared what other people
thought of me and I think that really
kind of served you no benefit to me in
this process because when it came down
to it I didn't really care what my
family had to say you know I do
encounter a lot of reverts Humberts
who do kind of struggle with how their
family is going to react and they're
they fear that they're gonna lose their
friends or their social circle and that
wasn't a concern for me my concern was
finding out the truth and I was somebody
who what I want to know that something I
will spend all day and all night trying
to figure it out so you know when it
came down to it you know telling my
parents you know it on one hand it was a
bit scary you know because I think more
than anything
probably my father I knew was gonna be a
little bit nerve-racking because he
definitely is kind of that scientist and
you know I was kind of on his side for
many years when we would talk about
religion and religious people and their
actions and maybe how the churches and
things like that so you know his
reaction was probably you know the most
shocking out of everybody my mom she was
really just kind of concerned for me but
you know for myself I again I just
didn't care what anybody else thought I
was happy with my choice I did go
through a little bit of anxiety here and
there you know because I was coming from
such a different lifestyle is coming
from a lifestyle where it's okay
for girls to wear mini shorts and tank
tops and stiletto high heels and
beautify themselves and go to the clubs
and have guy friends and you know have
your occasional glass of wine and you
know all that was very very acceptable
you know and so for me it's like I kind
of had to get myself out of that thought
process and really dive deep into
educating myself and them so that I can
fully understand why I was making these
changes and Hum Dil ah I tell all the
girls that I speak with that I feel that
God really does kind of put us in
certain situations in our past to make
us understand it's them a bit better and
everything that a lot of girls come to
me with that they're struggling with
whether it's having guy friends or
having boyfriends or stop drinking
alcohol or whatever it may be I have a
story in my past that I can relate it to
and understand why allah subhanho wa
taala has asked these things of us you
know and so i think that it's been
really great i think that you know when
a convert comes into the faith education
is the best thing to kind of relieve
yourself of any of that anxiety and when
you really start to have faith in allah
and what he has in store for you and
your journey you're not gonna care about
what anybody else has to say
we know islam one of the the main things
that it's there for is to help us to
become better human beings to have the
best manners and character and that's
all built on that pure monotheism having
a direct connection with the creator and
everything he's told us to do is good
for us and everything he told us to stay
away from is harmful for us one of the
things after you've established that
connection the prayer and because we
need it it's our medicine one of the
things that many women struggle with is
the job so what do you I mean you coming
from a background now that you you know
you did it many people there they take
for granted being born into a Muslim
family you coming from
a family that wasn't Muslim and now you
stucked up you you know he's wearing
hijab how do you encourage those those
women out there who are having a hard
time you know with this wearing of the
hijab what do you usually tell them to
motivate them you know I think that when
I always try to approach sisters and you
know their difficulties you know because
we all have our own difficulties whether
small or big they're our own and they're
different and I always try to kind of
give them you know it's either Islamic
perspective but as well you know I do
kind of try to be sensitive to you know
their emotion and what they're going
through and kind of give them a little
bit of friend or sister advice as well
um you know but I think that you know if
you're really just gonna kind of spell
it out you know one thing I really say
just to dive right into it is that at
the end of the day cadaver is a choice
if when you say choice
you mean ultimately yeah kara let me
give this to you you know if I'll tell
it ultimately you mean that truly
everything that you do in your life is a
choice we know that pray 5 times a day
it says like that is mandated of us as
Muslims it's a part of our 5 pillars but
it's still a choice I mean we can choose
to do those 5 prayers or we can choose
to do one or none you know so for me
it's like when talking to girls I have
to let them know yes is a choice but it
is something I truly believe is
mentioned in the Quran as something that
us as women need to do as Muslims is it
as in wear it as other things like
prayer maybe nice but I think that as
Muslim women we have to recognize the
things that we have to do in our faith
to please Allah to better ourselves as
Muslims and if we're not at least taking
those steps and really truly
understanding why and
fact that we need to anyways we're not
going to get anywhere you know so it's
really kind of that understanding of it
is a choice but it's a choice that's
going to be better for us and better for
our Deen it's going to be better for our
practice and insha'Allah you know you
may not be perfect right now
but you can work towards it I do
unfortunately have a lot of girls who
kind of come to me who say well my net
personality isn't very modest so how am
I going to be modest on the outside and
I really think that just kind of comes
down to education and becoming closer
with your faith to truly understand what
modesty is to you because I really do
think that modesty is different for
everybody but I think that just because
you're lacking in one area doesn't mean
that you should totally give up on
another area you know it's kind of about
combining the two and finding a happy
balance for yourself thank you so much
for being on the Dee's show spending
time with our viewers out there we
really you know love hearing these
stories of people who have been able to
step up be courageous enough and to find
peace and purpose in Islam and share
their wonderful journey so more people
can benefit thank you so much Oakland I
think another wonderful story here on
the Dee show you got to really be
somewhat of a iconoclastic someone who
defies traditions you can't be that dead
fish in the ocean just going with the
flow even the fish goes against many of
the currents and that's what you got to
do if you want to know the truth you got
to dig for the treasure because it's
worth your time it's worth your effort
and you see what she said she said after
going through what many people go
through they end up having a thousand
and one different purposes but they
don't live the true purpose and now
she's found it and she wouldn't she
wouldn't trade it for the world and
everything in it and that's her story
and you could be someone out there who's
going through some of the many
challenges that we go through life you
will never find true absolute happiness
in this life following your desires
but but there's good news and she was a
she's a living testimony to that and so
are they over one point what is it five
six billion people now out there who are
have accepted his way of life that's
logical rational they just called you to
something very simple to have a direct
dial-up connection with the one who made
you who created you and Jesus did it he
lived this way of life so did his
Blessed Mother Mary and that's what
she's doing so now when you go ahead and
look at the return on your investment
when you live this way of life compared
to living a way of life of debauchery
following your lusts and your passions
and your desires hitting this dead end
that dead end and at the end you just
had a dead end call us
you